[Music]
feels like I've been walking on
everything going feel alright in the
drum bodies oh honey time we gonna have
a good time
a dozen hands up to the sky we gonna get
toasted
I wanna lose
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy October first a
national holiday here at the morning
toast if you don't know why educate
yourself and it's just I need this day
never passes without me having a huge
pit I know but it is like a nice marker
of time you know yes like we've now been
doing the show for at least three you
know it's been like I you thinking it's
been two years since that wild day but
time really flies when you're having fun
it's just what we do here at the morning
toast and for anyone who wanted an
update I never got the money but I
donated $200 in his name to save horizon
which is like an organization for
victims of violence and I did that
because I thought I was gonna get the
200 but I didn't like now I'm out 400
right but you know he gave us so much
content that the honest today can't put
a price on and the kind of camaraderie
he instills in the toasters communities
you know invaluable you really can't buy
that sorta but I did know but yeah I get
I guess you did but you couldn't if you
wanted to no I know it's just it's so
valuable I'm not upset and it's all good
and it's all good
I'm wearing a very toasty bomber jacket
say I'm very toasty as well today I'm
wearing toast merch which should be
coming rather soon this is Joe's merch
that's not toast no no sorry but I'm
just saying merch should be coming up
yeah very soon so gird your loins it's
gonna be a good one decided announced
some kinks we have so much to recap
there was Dancing with the Stars last
night I was in Malibu this weekend what
else
shuttin it's a new year we're sitting in
here new year new me it's exciting
nothing like a new year to just get your
mind right something about the Jewish
New Year feels very more like clean
slate to me like spiritually then
January 1st I feel as though Jewish New
Year is a mental new year and January
1st is like a physical new year where my
resolutions are more physical and for
the Jewish New Year my resolutions are
more mental who do I want to be what
I want to do what do I want to stop
doing right and we have this short time
period between the New Year and Yom
Kippur we're on the new year it is
written victim on Yom Kippur it is
sealed so what you do the book of life
what you do in this time period is very
interesting it's ten days and it's maker
break so we're gonna be on our best
behavior yeah because I want to be
written into the book of life it's also
a special time of year like our dad died
this time of year which I think makes it
better I think like rumor has it that
you go straight to hell I think that's
what the rumors say but you get tabloids
or so on a lot legend has it speaking of
tabloids and rumors one of our stories
today is straight from the morning
toasters Facebook group which is
something we've never done before and
I'm really excited about it because I
want the story to be true and not only
that I find that the morning shows first
Facebook group is really the breeding
ground of so much hot gossip that
eventually makes it way to the main
makes its way to the mainstream news and
we never get credit for it from the
toaster space right no but we're part of
the problem because we only consider it
news when he writes it up but it's like
no we have it here just like that girl
who spotted her engagement ring she put
that story in the toasters and then and
she yes she got toaster when I was
reading this story I was like this
sounds I don't know like a toaster and
she put the story in one of the toasters
group and it just made its way through
the internet and NBC San Francisco and
picking it up and then we picked it up
but it was our girl oh my god
that's the last time we let something
like that happen right so that's why
today whether it's true or not you know
we're gonna let you know what what the
toasters on the ground were saying yeah
and you know what medias constantly
reporting news that's not true so I
don't wait I can't wait
yeah actually looks like news we want to
see in the world like it is confirmed
that Brad Pitt and Kourtney Kardashian
well that's not that's like a
manifesting like if we talked about it
enough it probably will happen
yeah weirdo like see all these rumors
circulating there's so much positive
like their poll numbers are going up I
just watch the politics we also have to
recap the politicians yeah which we will
at the end when the snatcher gets here
because right now we are snitch is
missing in action
we are snitch las' it's it's a snitch
you probably felt it you were like
something's off
yeah it's a snitch list situation it's
not good it's just a situation yeah but
she'll be she'll be here soon and we're
just counting down the minute we're just
gonna fire her the second she walks in
know we can need her so Before we jump
in how was your weekend how's your trip
it was actually delightful like I didn't
think I was gonna I
like never do trips I know you you know
me I never do influencer trips partly
because I don't get asked but also
partly because it's just not my thing
like honestly the idea of ever going on
a revolve trip sounds like my actual
worst nightmare you know what valve
trips like compared to some of the other
influence or trips where it's like
really an amalgam of people who don't
know each other I feel like that's not
the worst kind of influencer trip but I
just don't think it's for me like being
in that type of environment like would
make me really like conscious for a
bikini company yeah and it's like I
think that they have itineraries like
boom boom boom like you don't have any
time to relax and you're in this like
beautiful place and you don't get to
enjoy it so I was honestly very
reluctant to do this trip and I was
gonna say no but I thought they told me
that Lauren Elizabeth was going I said
okay I'll go because I never get to see
her and a weekend in Malibu with Lauren
Elizabeth okay and I got there and I
didn't really know who was gonna be
there and it was such a great crew of
people I got to see so many people
haven't seen in so long like Morgan
Stewart and Camille Kasich and then I
got to meet some new people like
Charlotte McKinney who is like literally
the most beautiful girl on the face of
the earth and I couldn't be more normal
really it was a who's who of influencers
like it was premium as hell and then I
got someone who just enjoys everyone's
content like I was really living it's
like it's like that all it's like Real
Housewives Allstars or what the NBA
all-stars I imagine is it's like your
dream team yeah winters got together and
it sounds like it was as good as you
thought it was it was because like it
was just so it wasn't everyone was like
it wasn't the type of people who usually
go on these trips you know like know how
to be fake everyone's like I don't
normally do this ya know right and then
they were like it was just a dress
please have a she's so beautiful
how are you are you watching us to get
here I say that we missed you and that
we were gonna fire you this because I'm
all service so I do not hear that but I
feel like you say they here gonna fire
but you won plead your case like do you
wanna keep this she's coming from a job
interview she don't give a [ __ ]
and also I told you guys I know but it
doesn't make it any easier and it just
seems like your job requires you to work
one hour a day and this interview could
have been maybe at the other 20-odd to
say I offered an 800 other times and
they couldn't accept I mean I mean
you're gonna get the job cuz look at you
who wouldn't hire that who what helps
you're so proficient in your field
snatchler thank you I just like back to
talking about me I wanted to give him as
your shout-out because I met Jackie
Chimel who is the [ __ ] Bible yeah we
had a lot of questions how did it go
because everywhere I was reading The
Chosen when I woke up like from my
flight and people already starting
posting in Malibu cuz I got there super
late people were like oh Jackie she was
there the Claude he's gonna hate her
she's gonna hate Claudia and I'm like oh
my god why like what and I got there and
she's like so cool and pretty and like
nice and like I left her and she's like
my new best friend we were jamming um
and I was just like I wonder why people
thought we weren't gonna get along
I went unit I was gonna ask you didn't
see why people might have thought that
nobody actually told her that because a
lot of the girls who work for vital
proteins are two toasters and they were
like showing us the threads of like
people thought we weren't gonna get
along and I was like I wonder why but
like I was being truly myself I wonder
why - interesting maybe it's I think
it's like when when their big
personalities in a room like sometimes
they they often clash but I thought
everyone was really harmonious you know
it is a group of women who support other
women that's exactly what it was and it
was just I had such a good time and not
to mention I'm glad you had a good time
I always like complain about going to
the stuff and now we can use this
against you
to go to for you to go to the next thing
well it didn't hurt that it was probably
the most luxurious trip I've ever
experienced or even witnessed we stayed
at the Nobu hotel in Malibu which I
didn't even know there was a no blue
hotel I knew there was a Nobu restaurant
so it's right next door and it's an
invite only like 20 room Hotel on the
beach it's [ __ ] sick like there was
not a bad room in the house like I did
up one of the better ones you know I was
being starved not just like going into
people's rooms like saying if mine was
nicer um and it was just so luxe they
had facialists and yoga which I did
participate in but I watched from my
balcony and there was no itinerary like
it was just basically like have fun
enjoy like the whole premise of the trip
was like you guys worked so hard like
just have a good time they only had a
dinner every night which was so luxe
like this dinner at Nobu Malibu like oh
my god I was having the time of my life
open bar like you know I got so drunk in
a second I think we all do it but I mean
I woke up like a pig you know but
everyone was like what happened last
night so I was like oh nobody knows that
I was being crazy because everyone was
being crazy right and everybody said on
this show that she wasn't gonna drink
maybe have a dyke oh she had a glass of
wine on the plane I did yeah and you
know I got [ __ ] up on the plane she's
snitching
how did you know that cuz you snapped it
I wrote TOS like and I have mine Jameses
again miners always like being a teddy
mountain camp and it's a little annoying
but they were giving up champagne and I
was like you know what it's a weekend
like what I cannot drink champagne I was
I one drink and I couldn't my eyes were
like whirling behind my head I was like
Chinese a beverage it's a crazy beverage
I haven't had champagne like it's just
not my drink of choice
I had a burp at my anniversary and I had
three glasses and I had to be carried on
it just makes you like so lightheaded
for like a short amount of time but
you're not there for a long time but
you're there for a good time I don't
know it's kind of sounds fun yeah it was
such honestly was such a good time I was
like really grateful for the invitation
seeing as how it was like this premium
group of influencers haleyss a list and
I was like so grateful and I really had
the best time and I like when I was
leaving I was like sad like it felt like
summer camp you know yeah well maybe you
guys can keep in touch
yeah well Heather lives here Morgan I
definitely to see like I have now like I
have la friends now you know yeah I'm
definitely a hit up Charlotte McKinney
like Pharrell on to something
Oh for real well we're going back to LA
in less than two weeks yes we have LA
week starting October 13th mm-hmm
Premium guests being nailed down left
and [ __ ] right also I have a
show October 13th right before LA Week
starts Jackie and Marga are gonna be
there it is the ACE theater tickets
available at galco.com
thank you that's gonna be a fun week I'm
looking forward to it I actually am too
we just need to get our bearings like
we're booked flights booked a hotel you
know booked everything yeah but I think
I'm thinking maybe we should rent a
house oh my god you would freak out of
here actually okay I've been in the
hills it's so spooky should read like a
penthouse I think we should say at the
Chateau Marmont
okay yes at a hotel or just a club it's
not a club at Hotel perfect yeah
actually when you party at like one of
the villas there that was like you know
a million dollars a night I think when
she got that one okay cool
yeah I'll arrange it sweet well we have
a great show for you today we have to
recap politician turns with the stars
I've been watching money heist on
Netflix I'm well into season two and I
just don't know if I would recommend it
I thought you were blowing up our child
look useless in religion of it to the
people to a chowder people who watch it
explain
Nach ler whenever the chat is popping
off like that I might ooh what's the T
yeah and she's like Berlin is annoying I
mean a sociopath
I wonder if any of the toasters are
watching it it's a it's pretty good and
I've just been like really bored and
it's the perfect show because it's
keeping me I feel like it's similar to
24 where it's not every minute is an
episode but similar but you know I must
show me four times leaving silly no but
I know that the premise is like 60
minute episode it's real 60 minutes yes
24 hours in a day yes you see every
minute of their lives that's how it's
feeling um cuz it's just really slow but
I'm enjoying it and I'm really like
excited to go home and watch it even
though I hate it so you know that
feeling
yes I do I do you know I do I just gonna
see what stupid thing they're gonna do
next Jackie I know that feeling in the
back of my thing I mean if I'm rooting
for the good guys are the bad guys I
don't care really I just want everyone
to stop being so stupid oh also we need
to schedule yesterday's episode we
really don't want to do a show yesterday
because it was Russia Shana it felt like
sacrilegious but any grandma was in town
and when Andy Grammer called you pick up
the phone then he ended up double
booking us so it all worked out so weird
the item back on the toast eventually
Margo into his concert on Saturday said
it was amazing and it was I was sad that
I couldn't like be here harmonize with
him but we had to go to shul anyway and
I thought my Jewish guilt was really
really advanced my Jewish guilt it
sounds a lot of like just scheduling
yeah moral problem yeah and I'm glad we
went to shul starting the new year off
alright but we were being like such
Gossip Girls in shul like exactly what
people think like we were just sitting
there in the back like just looking at
everyone you know well I feel like we
always know - well on Yom Kippur and
it's so somber and everyone like has bad
breath because you can't eat and you
okay Rosh Hashanah is really just like a
geyser operation and it's like a fashion
show you know everyone can wear their
perfumes and use a towel and wears like
leather shoes yeah yeah and so we were
just the in like Gossip Girl it was fun
it was fun it felt like an episode of
like GCB but like yeah jewish JTB gjb
and also everyone else is very Jewish it
was a sea where everyone else was
staring - yeah everyone else is getting
like the one - totally um those shoes
really Margo that dress you don't like
that dress no I love this dress actually
give me Seinfeld yeah
so do you think I think I don't know
it's been 13 minutes I think we're good
to go I think it's time to launch into
the fast 5 stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
for sure but I want to see does anyone
does anything different about me
particularly my upper body I would say
your hair is just on another wavelength
no pun intended like good to do and
that's because I Bruce Lee made the
switch to function of beauty and I'm not
gonna lie oh excuse me what really
attracted me to function of beauty was
two things one they put your name on the
bottle so then Ben knows not to touch my
[ __ ] - the bottles of shampoo and
conditioner are [ __ ] enormous so you
never have to run out like I use a huge
puddle of product every time I wash my
hair like I'm not one of these girls
just like Oh what quarters just sides
like a dollop no and running out of
shampoo was probably one of the most
annoying things ever I'm with function
of beauty it very rarely happens we all
know the frustration bottles and bottles
piling up in your bathroom each one
falsely promising a miracle solution
that only kind of work but what if there
was just one shampoo that could truly do
it all we all don't have the same hair
so why should we all use the same same
shampoo and conditioner great [ __ ]
point function of beauty brings you
shampoos and conditioners that are
customized and individually filled just
for you most drugstore brands only
address a single concern like volume
eyes and strengthen with function of
beauty you can choose up to five hair
goals to add to your formulation so
obviously a lot of my when I took the
quiz have to do with moisture because
I've been like recently in my old age
having like dry crusty hair and I used
to have like shiny beautiful hair and
it's just not gonna work for me anymore
yeah but that's my function beauty is
here they individually formulate every
bottle based on your hair type your hair
girls and your preferences you can
select your color and fragrance or you
can opt for a dye free or fragrance free
the products are so personalized that
your name is even printed on the bottle
so you're grabbing husband cannot get
his hands on it function of Beauty never
utilizes any sulfates parabens
flatulates
mineral oils or any harmful ingredients
that you can't pronounce because if you
can't pronounce it it shouldn't be in
your goddamn hair the sad reality is
that most major drugstore brands test on
animals function of beauty is 100% vegan
and cruelty-free and if you care about
the O you will go to function of beauty
calm right now here we go
listeners of our show who we love will
receive 20% off their first order to
redeem had to function at beauty calm /
toast and take their hair profile quiz
go to function of beauty calm /
toast to get 20% off your custom formula
and you care about your hair and you
care about the function of beauty calm /
toast for 20% of your custom formula why
do they need to test shampoo on dogs
like it makes no sense
it makes no sense like tested on
yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah how is
Theo you know more precious and
beautiful than ever he had a day out in
the country yesterday because we went to
Ben's uncle's house in New Jersey has a
huge yard and there was like little deer
and Thea was just like with his people
and he was so pooped you know in the car
like sleeping on my lap he's just he's
something special he's something special
okay well speaking of something special
the beauty of love and marriage Justin
Bieber and Haley Baldwin marry again in
South Carolina ceremony it is like what
honestly I feel like everyone tries to
keep their wedding hush-hush but like I
can not find any pictures except for
like one blurry paparazzi picture on
world of jaylee like world jelly and
they released one picture from a photo
booth like you can't see a dress they
might as well be at someone else's
wedding like it's yeah it's nothing I
can't see your makeup and it I thought
it was so weird that like everyone knew
like the wedding starting in an hour
like it was so public but it ended up
being so private except I saw one
picture of groom's Ben Carl Lentz was a
groomsman and so was Dave Grubman and so
is Jason Kennedy really yes that's weird
yeah that's crazy I don't know who's in
it just a gentleman them yeah Kendall
and Kylie were there which I was
surprised by because Kylie doesn't leave
France or anything yeah I think some of
the Smith kids were there Jaden Smith
you Jaden I just want to see more like
let's go
yeah do you think she's gonna do vogue
weddings like with an exclusive oh
pretty sure they'd love a Vogue
exclusive she is just like so beautiful
so stylish and like I think she knows
that she's got it all going on and she
wants to share that with the world but
in you know a Vogue type of way and I
just be cruel if she did it and I just
need to say like thank God that Justin
Bieber looked great yeah he looked like
og like not looking a little different
these days and I'm glad he would look
like his ten year old self from that
YouTube video yeah they say they really
looked so cute did you see the pictures
of him getting on that boat oh my god
she is so like classic elegant chic like
she could be a royal yes that boat was
very royal because like she carries her
so well and she also doesn't say that
much which is great because she doesn't
get herself into trouble right we could
learn a thing or two from her we could I
just love her I think she's so beautiful
I actually believe in their love you
know yeah yeah the way they initially
got started like I've engaged so fast as
there was a lot of like skepticism
around it especially like given like the
Selena of it all like there was just so
much keep into a time of failed
engagements like Ariana and Pete right
right Nick and Priyanka not failed but
no I hear you and I just really believe
in their love and I think they're doing
a good job of like not addressing any of
the rumors just like proving us wrong
with their love yeah also like if you
had told me like Hailey and lastly like
Halley and Justin are gonna have a big
ceremony you know to celebrate their
wedding I would be like okay like who
cares but I didn't realize how much I
needed this
like I'm so here for it I didn't know
how much I needed like Kylie to charter
a plane to go to her friend's wedding
and ride the house and and bring her
daughter and be a normal kid I just read
something that Kylie does every single
time she does something she always goes
home that night because she's a genius
but like don't I don't know like that's
so much work like you're at a party then
should I sell you just get on a boat you
fly private like most like if after
every show you and I could go home or go
to the next city on a plane we would but
flights don't run past like 11 or 10 get
the airport it's technically close from
12 to 6 which sucks but if you've a
private plane it's like having a car
waiting for you like okay what it takes
you two hours to get home you get to
sleep in your own bed there's literally
when I watched Joan Rivers uh
documentary she got on a private plane
and like after working like literally a
36 hour day and she looked in the camera
and she said there's nothing like
sleeping in your own bed and she was
right and I would rather be tired
exhausted displace for an extra three
hours then go to sleep and wake up and
go home the next day yeah also like she
can sleep on the plane and maybe you
never know like maybe she was gonna stay
at the house like the a/c was broken and
she was just like let's get on the plane
yeah also when it actually puts you in
danger like when so many people know
where you are
like if because of the wedding if Kylie
spent the night at a house I'm sure
there's only so many houses in this
particular area that are good enough for
Kylie to stay in she's a target she I
get out yeah I feel and she could sleep
on the plane maybe it's like such a
great bed out in the plane and she does
sure she used
Instagram story so much I went her in
Jordan would like charter planes like
they made this huge bed like nicer than
my bed at home like on the plane it's
it's looks yeah and so she was flying
with Chris was Chris at the wedding she
was on the plane with Chris Chris should
have been at the wedding because Cory is
a friend of Justin so they probably were
probably where they met through Justin I
don't forget yes Wow Wow I would Chris
pics yeah Chris is just after watching
new season of Kardashians like I have a
newfound appreciation for Chris Jenner
and I think that like she is the most
underappreciated woman not only in the
family but in industry yeah I think
she's definitely super appreciated but
it should be even more appreciation she
does get enough credit yeah I think was
like a devil it's hard but Kris Jenner
it's hard no Christian is a [ __ ]
genius leave her alone
yeah only smarter than Christian men
Snitch Jenner yes the only one but she
has a very high IQ because since Jenner
she does she'll just snatch them out
what a beautiful story what a beautiful
ending to their love I just beginning
yeah but like of this like it's like the
end of them being children the beginning
of them being adults yes this is an
adult wedding yeah yeah they're so young
actually it's time to grow up okay
well next story is a crazy one Gigi
Hadid confronts crasher who stormed the
Chanel runway at Paris Fashion Week a
crasher storm the runway Chanel spring
2020 presentation Tuesday morning at the
Grand Palais dressed in a black and
white tweet outfit topped with a black
hat the spectator climbed onto the set
which was built to look like Paris
rooftops as models took their finale
walk Women's Wear Daily leader
identified the crasher as Marie Ben
allele 28 best known as maurice
infiltration with 220 thousand YouTube
subscribers and one hundred and one
hundred ninety six thousand followers on
Instagram she has a one-woman show now
on the comedy dash M still is a theater
in Paris okay this reminds me of that
prankster youtuber who picked up Gigi
Hadid in Milan remember yes and I just
like when I saw this say it's such a bit
surreal reaction to it like this girl's
an [ __ ] nice hole do you know how
many people like worked hard to make
this show that Karl Lagerfeld is rolling
over in his grave I'm so glad he's not
alive to see they're letting over in his
grave
this is I hate people who like sorry
you're not a comedian because you're an
[ __ ] like you ruin people's days like
ruin like multimillion-dollar
productions also the worst part was
those shoes she was wearing she tried to
fit in she was running like a tweed
pants but you know it all it was she did
well she's wearing these ugly
clodhoppers wedges and she was like I
mean it was so annoying I don't know
what if you want to like poke fun at the
fashion world and do this like don't do
an action l know I just don't think okay
let's say you don't like the fashion
world what it stands for like [ __ ] off
like this is people's jobs like I just
hate people who are like just have like
so little regard for like Authority like
I find these people to be like menaces I
arrest you know I'm such a visceral
reaction and be like she's trespassing I
don't know how did she even get in there
I mean I just I don't know know what
it's because like the fashion world in
vogue is like inviting all these
youtubers and influent I mean always
influencers but like youtubers mostly
comedic youtubers from like no business
being at the Chanel show you know she is
now like ruining and Fashion Week for a
million other youtubers yeah you know
what I'm okay with that I just I thought
this was such an [ __ ] thing to do I
didn't think it was funny like I didn't
think and if she was trying to make a
statement about like whatever the
fashion world is deeply problematic I
agree but like I just thought this was
such like an [ __ ] thing to do like so
really girls like on that show like it's
her first time walking Chanel like
they've been dreaming of this their
whole lives and like this girl took the
spotlight away like I just think she's
an [ __ ] I can't say it in any other
way
she's a prick okay but she doesn't even
have a message it's not like she came on
there in a shirt that said you know
something provocative she just wanted
attention but I will say I want to thank
her because she drew a lot of attention
to the Chanel show which I hadn't seen
until I saw this story and the
collection is so adorable adorable Gigi
looked adorable and two's yelling at her
well so that's the best part is if you
watch the video the girl that gets a
little lost on the on the Paris truth
time she ends up near Gigi Hadid and
Gigi literally takes her by the arm and
escorts her off like good for Gigi for
being a hero
yeah literally yeah like I'm sure it was
like awkward and like some people might
not have known the girl that she walked
in front of they were all walking and
then she hopped on stage and cut this
girl off she was so confused and by the
way these bottles are so professional
not one of them blinked an eye they just
kept going yes yes reminded me of
Rockettes like with the following
soldiers like yeah it kind of look like
that when they like she did the the
order the rhythm yeah I just I don't
think this is funny I hope she doesn't
get followers from this or at like
positive attention because this is such
an [ __ ] thing to do I totally agree
like ruining people and by the way this
is the first show of the collection of
the new designer I forget her name like
it's a big moment for her like you're
just being an [ __ ]
yeah but she is drawing eyeballs to it
so I'm happy for the new designer I
wouldn't have seen it those cute little
rompers it was very cute it was so cute
it was so cute and this is like the
first post Karl collection and and I
have high hopes
is this a felony like you get arrested
that's passing so no the security really
could have been on their toes a little
bit more they don't want to disrupt the
show obviously Gigi handled it perfectly
yes true actually I didn't think about
that and now he's always forward that
she'll get paid her Model T and like a
secured anything yeah she's about to go
that guy picked her up that old prank
video do you ever seen if she was
walking from her car to her hotel it was
like a 10 foot walk and there was like
tons of people outside and this guy he's
like a Milan prankster youtuber came up
and picked her up and she [ __ ]
elbowed him in the face like she is a
beast like she need how to defend
herself yeah that's how Yolanda Hadid
blood yeah yeah these pranksters though
like what are you doing yeah I don't
know I just have no time for pranks no
me neither and I have no time for people
who have made their bearings on being
pranksters it's like you mean the career
off of being an [ __ ] yeah unless it's
fake Christian or getting tackled by a
security guard I have no time they're
pranking people like you know and
personally like that's okay look if I
prayed to you like as long as I'm we
don't cross a lot we're not pranksters
so like you can't create nobody knows
the difference between breaking your
family and like being an international
worldwide prankster
okay Oh crazy you know like
international madness prank and you know
I just I hate people like this the story
really pissed me off
no I totally agree but I just for the
record like we're not a pranking family
so don't get any I know we are not great
yes lebarge commented I just went to her
Instagram and it looks like she crashes
many shows like that's her mo yeah I'm
like a no-fly list
yeah the fashion shows crash
the wrong show yeah sure
your name came across the wrong newsdesk
oh yeah yeah Marie banelli L Oh a little
French twist French comedian yeah I
heard Champa never she's French camber
wooden wrench camper is a lot of things
but she has respect first imposes
personnel and the hour day and authority
and counselors this was just a crazy
story I totally agree okay next up a
little good news thank God Malika Hawk
is pregnant yes wow this is so exciting
Malika Hawks baby on the way is already
getting so much empty love she's also
getting so much money because she did
her pregnancy announcement is a
sponsorship for clearblue it is the
first time mom-to-be is showing off her
baby bump for the first time in a photo
shoot alongside her twin sister kinesia
who places her hand on Malika stomach
for the sweet shots love a little sister
the auntie love Maliha has been an
unseen just for a while now and a really
good one a really good one and it's time
that the tables have turned that she has
fellow devote events time child I think
it's like when you're an aunt you you
get back what you give and I think she's
about to get back a lot event you reap
what you sow you reap what you sow in
the ant world there were two major
questions here when Malika announced her
pregnancy is who was the father she's
always kept her love life very low-key
I'm just really hoping it's not Ronnie
magros from the Jersey Shore absolutely
not he is literally the most abusive
human being and like I just don't think
I don't get the vibe that he would be
like a good dad he is a dad and then the
second question is the ad so love to
hear your thoughts on like having a
sponsored pregnancy announcement here's
the it's not the first time I've seen it
I remember Audrina Patridge did it and I
didn't know how to feel that and I
sorted it out and now I know how to feel
with this company also that company ava
bracelets it's like the fertility
bracelet oh yeah there's yep you um you
know what how I feel is nice work if you
can get it yep you know if I don't know
if when how God willing knock on wood
you know bless would be the fruit I get
pregnant and if someone wants to sponsor
my announcement come through yeah ot
Genesis according to the comments is the
father
it is her ex I don't know him so I'll
have to do some research before I'd
Maclean's okay just this is such great
news I
like yeah and it's I'm just excited for
her and Chloe and then their little
babies will be similar age and they can
be best friends like Malika and Chloe
and yeah I just think it's it's so
exciting it is exciting and they've good
genes Malika oh yeah I'm Khadija cuz cuz
you just kids are cute yeah and the two
of them are so beautiful yeah I'm
excited for this probably one of the
most interesting factoids about Malika
and Khadijah ready I'm about to blow
your mind
is that they were in the movie sky high
remember that movie about like the
superhero school skies
yeah and that kid liked both his parents
are like the greatest superheroes like
yeah he's actually a sidekick you know
I'm Malika and Khadijah are those
cheerleaders who replicate themselves
yes oh my god yeah wow that is actually
such a good movie it's a fabulous movie
grab you danielle panabaker
part oh that's an amazing actually it is
[ __ ] I love that movie and the flying
school was yeah awesome yeah it's such a
good movie that's it that's great
yeah I wonder what happened to the
leaking could you use acting career I
guess they just got made that Kardashian
money and never looks back
yeah and this clear blue money yes out
who it is yep love it you know I'm gonna
get a clear boil okay I've actually
excuse me taking the clear blue a few
months ago I thought it was for sure
right now that was it spoiler alert
yeah it was not okay next story is just
cringe City and I need to get the
snatchers opinion the bachelorettes Mike
Johnson says Dan free oh she says stab
me Lovato made the first move end quote
kisses really well Craig if I was her
I'd be like why are you doing what I
want to read the quotes cuz the bachelor
Paradise star was recently a guest on
the almost famous podcast with Ben
Higgins and a sh t guy and he revealed
that not only had he and Demi Lovato
been going on dates but they've also
kissed quote we've gone on more than one
date quote I like her tattoos we both
have a lot of tattoos Demi has more than
me quote and she kisses really well like
first of all he's like a second grader
like and now I'm really understanding
why he wasn't us John say that imagine
how annoying if this is the one thing
he's saying about dating one person
imagine how annoying he'd be if he's
dating a Millie and I feel like she
really wouldn't like this like no like
so tomorrow we'll be reporting that
they're no longer yeah
there because this is just like nope do
you think that Tyler and Gigi aren't
together anymore I do I you think
they're together I don't mean either
really so the rumor mill is swirling he
finally is just giving interviews and I
say just for us and but that makes me
think that they are together also I
don't like if you're dating a celebrity
that's how you talk not that she has a
lot of tattoos and that you kissed her
right also she is traveling for work
right now so they wouldn't be seen
together actually Buffy yeah I just I
don't think you have the sort of
passionate love where you go to
someone's grandma's funeral and then
Netherlands and then break up less than
a month later be disappointing if they
did that's a good point she has been
working like between Paris Fashion Week
Milan and this or any guard like it's
it's like a month where you're out of
town so it has been a while since we
spotted them together but she hasn't
been in New York yeah and I guess people
could say like oh he should be traveling
with her and I would I think I'm a
terrible precedent to set for the
relationship so I'm glad that they're
not I do think they're still together
happy story this morning that he's
moving at him we stopped out of the food
you think he's moving to her building no
I think he got an apartment where do you
think it is I don't know that he's been
doing ads just making that money so he's
good he's good I don't know I don't know
if he's fine if the whole thing is just
is so crazy and I'm like worried about
him because it's a lot of attention it's
a lot of attention but it's also like he
moved to New York after the show right
yeah when I was living in New York when
the show aired from Jupiter so he's a
newbie to New York yeah he doesn't have
like that many friends here he starts
dating like a supermodel they're
spending so much time together but he
also like needs his own life I think
that he's like struggling a little bit
to like find his place post bachelor and
obviously like these are great problems
to have but I think he's in a weird spot
yeah and I think that's why he goes out
with all these other bachelor people I
think he's just trying to make friends
right well Margo broke the news that
they were spotted at he was spotted at
dinner in LA at catch with Christina
Shulman and then Margaret some follow-up
information that really saved the day
that they weren't on a date it was an
influence or a mat and then Cosmo picked
up Margo and it was they were I was
always saying my name but they just kept
saying what the snatchler set and the
snaps are dating I just think it's
natural this snacks or not and yes bring
it as the snatchler yes yeah which is
that the press can't pay for it's true
trust me I've tried so what are your
expert thoughts on Mike and demi lovato
after this interview like if he wants it
to work stop talking yeah shut your
mouth and I feel like Demi Lovato is
like very much into
like obviously everyone's like
interlocks but she's really into like
personality and I think she probably was
really attracted to Mike just like based
off of how he looks in what she saw on
TV and like now she's getting to know
him and like shows like what she sees
that's just like the vibe that I get
also like if they are dating and I'm
hooking up like why wasn't it dancing
Stars last right Jamie was that tenting
with a star sitting in the front row and
so was Zooey Deschanel and Jonathan
Scott were you okay I don't Caroline
there were so many people at Dancing
with the Stars last night like I asked
him did you see him
no he was like in wrote for you you had
to spot it but I know she's connection
and what's the OED Chanel's connection
to sorry's no glitzy they'll just let
anyone in these days yes but apparently
sitting behind them was the cast of my
crazy ex-girlfriend crazy ex-girlfriend
yeah they were just sitting there like I
was just it was star-studded interesting
I like that Joe and Lorna Lauren
Elizabeth
Lauren Elena made it another week we're
gonna be there for LA week October 14th
she has to make it one more week
everyone he says vote for Lauren lay
that just so we can get there okay I
think she's in a good place I don't
think she knows that worried about her
but actually last night can we recap
tense with the surgeon we don't see the
mantel story AB Italy we're already
talking about it just when I do when I
do the descriptions it's like good start
good story okay then the final story a
little straight from the source toasters
news someone posted in the morning
toasters some tea for you all today
my boyfriend Rumer Willis was there too
just sitting well cuz she's like a
Dancing with the Stars and she's our
unique violin didn't they like Dave for
a sec or something no they were both on
the same season of Dancing with the
Stars
the one that she won she won she won
it's so interesting who wins
it's whoever do you think it is yeah my
boy son works in Malibu and said Miley
Cyrus came in today and she was all over
Cody Simpson Caitlin and Liam who okay I
was in Malibu didn't see this so I just
wanted to put it out there that it might
not be true but actually I see this a
lot it might not be true for sure
because it's just you know he said she
said but I want it to be anybody like
love Cody Simpson on the surfboard music
video Gigi Hadid
my favorite music video ever I don't
know why him and Gigi Hadid couldn't
make it work because in reality like of
all the men she's dated like I really
shipped them like they were this like
boned I australian like yeah stuff where
yeah I know I know why they couldn't
make it work he was like her high school
like you know in celebrity world like
her high school boyfriend it's like she
went off to like you know the big school
and he's the small town boy and it never
worked and you know what
so shocked me that didn't work like his
career yeah well yeah well how would you
what would you say Cody Simpson honestly
like sometimes I think his sisters like
a bigger star yeah then he is and she
something this for me cuz this is no
right now but she is like a premium
Instagram she's like a full-time
influencer yeah I don't know what he
does I think he's like Radio Disney I
think he's big in Australia and he does
you know he does the round I think I
should probably us like a nice career a
nice about nobody gets like a lot of
[ __ ] like I'm always hearing about him
with hot girls for sure
yeah hi he's not for sure who would eat
here Matt um my size I'm just like oh
whatever if he ever comes across my desk
it's always said he was spotted like
with a hot girl
okay so then this tracks yeah I just
couldn't see Miley going for him I know
yeah when you don't go from like Liam
Hemsworth and then actually going from
Liam Hemsworth to Kaylin Carter like
actually makes sense for me cuz like
while Liam Hemsworth is like the most
amazing man on the planet ever any fun
I've ever created um Caitlin Carter is
so different that it's not even
competition right but then I just since
yeah you go from both of them to Cody
Simpson like that's truly a step down
yeah it is but maybe when you're like
just maybe it's like when you're so like
famous and like you are an icon and
you're dating people on your levels like
sometimes you just want someone below
you like so they appreciate you yeah I
think that's what's happening like Cody
Simpson like totally it would be just
like so honored to be in Miley's
presence and like when you're that
famous like you want that kind of
validation like Liam it's just as famous
arguably more famous than Miley like
yeah he doesn't need to like lick her
ass like maybe she wants her ass licked
yeah maybe you just want to date someone
where it's clear like you're in charge
I'm the queen you're in the sorry person
totally by the way I actually really
feel that call
yeah there's no confusion yeah I feel
that call - did you what guys watch I'm
Jonas Brothers tiny desk no no I saw
cliff but I haven't much but I love the
tiny desk thing I know you do Dancing
with the Stars okay um I actually
watched so I got home at like 9:15 and I
was done by 10 o'clock
I skipped through all the [ __ ] like
why they have to do a clip about Ray
Lewis even though he's not performing
like was so stupid I watch it just
because like I loved Ray Lewis cuz you
made me love real I was worried
people think there's more to the story I
haven't heard they showed the foot
disgusting so he had like a prior injury
from football that like was it flaring
up again and he had to step out
oh and then by the way they made us do
this whole episode just to tell about
him - you're both staying because Ray
Lewis is out that's really a no yeah I
was really annoying but also I was
really good he was bad him to Lamar
Lamar and palmetto he'll Mitchell which
was shocking because I thought his
performance was beautiful but he has no
fans like yeah no one votes for him
that's where the show gets unfair yeah
because like Sean Spicer should've been
in the bottom two like not Kel Mitchell
interesting but it's honestly the
transgressor probably does half the
country and he's not a good dancer whoo
Sean Spicer if you've had one week he
was good last week this week he no you
know what it look like his dance it was
two cha-cha-cha no Saturday live said
that fever tonight be the night fever
and then he had like a lot of extras
like trying to make it like just taking
away from the fact that he didn't know
any of the steps and he's just like it's
something he's a bad dancer it's like no
sorry it's something yeah no he's a bad
answer
he Karen of the steps and him of the
Maura totally should have been in the
bottom two but it was really shocking
cuz I feel like it's only been one week
but I'm really like thinking there's so
many good people like who's gonna win
obviously I'm getting the vibe that the
network is trying to get Hannah to win
um they just give her like the best
timeslot always like she it's the best
she I find that she posts on Instagram
like professional picture it's like she
gets those pictures first like yeah I
just used I can't tell you why but I
feel like she's getting special
treatment
yeah I feel like ABC well they love her
and I feel like they owe her something
you know yeah like she didn't win last
time maybe she'll win this time I know
but hey what's really stirring she's
great so nobody's starting to bother me
about her though and she keeps talking
about like what she took I've been
through a lot like there are actually
people who have been through a lot like
you went on TV and I got super famous
and now have a lot of money and like are
on TV again and you just don't have a
boyfriend like you haven't been through
a lot I just want to put it out there
like I feel like I'm sure they want her
to harp on like the bathroom but like
yeah let's let's refrain from using that
phrase and hold it for people who
actually have been through seven loss
here you know I agree but I do think for
her she's been through a lot
yeah like I was like finding out that
her fiance has been lying to her it's
like sort of similar to a money heist
no I'm sorry I just I don't think she's
been through a lot like I think her life
could be better okay I think she's like
I think a little hard on her but yeah in
the scale of her life
comparing her to herself in the past
year she's had a harder time than in
other years and then she did become
really famous no I'm like she's things
couldn't be going better for her like
she gets I guess she's so beloved like
okay so she had a week where she didn't
know like who to trust and still
everyone was on her side in that week
she's beloved by literally everyone yes
it it's Lily um okay let's talk about
the dancing Allie Brooke really turned
it out I loved that Selena song because
I'm G so it was just a beautiful dance I
thought she did a great job and she
finally got scores that reflected how
she actually performed because she is
the most underscored person on the show
and it really bothers me so when I think
of the people who could actually win
based on talent I think of Allie Brooke
I think of Lauren Lena I think kind of
brown and they think james van der beek
james Van Der Beek is [ __ ] phenomenal
I know but I always get so frustrated
because it's so much easier for a guy to
be good than a girl but he'd like to
close the photo great okay agree but I'm
sure when it comes down to it it's also
easier for a girl to when she's better
to be more impressive than a guy you're
like razzle dazzle yeah you know you're
so impressed by some girl doing flame
yeah but it's harder for you to be
impressive because like everything's on
you like the dance if you move your foot
the wrong way when the girl is the
professional dancer like they don't miss
a beat so that you don't have to look at
who I'm sure that helps you succeed in
the dance but when it comes down to the
final two and it's a man versus a woman
say it's so much easier to be impressed
by what the female can do that is doing
yeah because she can do war right so I
think right now it makes it easier for
men but it just leaves you more
eventually you're only impressed by the
women yeah unless the man starts you
know flipping in the air well actually
Khurram oh did a jump blast yeah Crump
Joe I think he jumped over someone like
he did a leapfrog it was very sad yeah
we set the bar so low for him but
actually I was really surprised because
when he was performing I thought he was
doing so good and then the judges like
that was awful judges hate him they hate
him and like guess he missed up one time
but like who cares I thought it was such
a fun good he did like Rocket Man uh
Johnny I'm still standing and they had
Taron Egerton call in like it was really
like I thought it was such a cute
performance and I was really shocked
that like it was universally like awful
according to everyone
also carrie Ann and Ann Arbor she want
you to be such a [ __ ] last night she
tries too hard to be like Len
like the simon cowell yeah yeah and i
just want to say one of the most
underrated people on the entire show is
Kate Flannery from the office oh my god
big time in her clip apparently she's on
tour with Jane Lynch they sing so Jane
Lynch was there and you know I just love
the hardest working woman industry Jane
Lynch and Kate Flannery kills it every
time she's one of the highest scoring
people and she's definitely at a
disadvantage she said like I'm already
it's already hard enough being my age in
this industry and like I don't want to
look like a fool and she doesn't she
looks better than anyone she also could
win she could win I just know if she has
a fan base the office I know but like
she doesn't have stand culture like
everyone getting their moms phones and
the brothers phones to kolchin time my
texts last night is literally voted for
everyone ten times I would you vote for
I voted for Lamar Lamar Lauren Hannah
James you can't vote for everyone my
only vote I just like get excited and
then I'm scared they're not getting vote
so then I just do it okay it's not sure
if you can only but have voted for one
person last night who would have been
last night or who do I want to win
different question last night um it's
about Wow i think james van der beek I
really like him no I really want lorna
later win because i know her and then
who do you want to win you don't need to
vote for them right now cuz they're
probably doing fine had around okay um
the audience was just on fire like there
were so many celebs i can't wait to go I
can't wait I can't wait to be invited at
wig wig it's just a good show like I
actually really enjoyed watching it
usually a two-hour like reality show
like The Bachelor I find to be like I
dread it you know but I actually really
enjoy Dancing with the Stars I'm slowly
becoming one of my favorites I'm sorry
that it took so long I'm so happy for
you guys it's like good music bad voices
and you know what I'm enjoying the recap
yeah like that's so I'm sure I don't
watch no it's like I'm getting the high
point I'm actually interested to know
what's going on and I just don't want to
watch it so this is perfect for all I
decided so interesting that hat around
to dance to that song from bridesmaids I
know today so matter it said everyone
got really cute like story lines I
thought she got like gypped with the
yeah but your bridesmaid like making fun
of the fact that she's not engaged like
I don't like oh they I think that's what
it is I know he was like her best
friend's bachelorette party that week
like it was
so fake they also like she could have
just said anything that she loves yeah
he was actually pretty good away with
movies yeah movie night
so Lauren Elaine that was pretty woman
she looked so cute she had like her
heart leg up on the hood of a car yeah
that's a great theme and then if someone
didn't choose well I would judge them
but like helmet chill had the Titanic
and it was like very beautiful yeah Aly
Brooke had Selena so loved it I thought
they chose good movies except for Hannah
brown I mean they said bridesmaids I was
like what song is from bridesmaids yeah
and the only one yeah I mean it's a
little bit like trying to be relatable
if I roll like you and I did not like it
what's your favorite movie what's the
favorite song yeah absolutely Cooke was
pretty good like she doesn't have my
vote and she looks like this looked like
a man to see for each were like a like a
Grecian blue dress no wonder he's great
a showman no it's not of course not
bachelor gala brings Leigh Cook was good
yeah why did she did Mamma Mia yes dad
really it was also like her mom like
they're so close it was actually like a
cute little package yeah that's really
cute
yeah that's a good choice yeah and I'd
looked so like okay Hannah Brown should
have done Miss Congeniality
yes she's beauty and she's great uh-uh
or what's that song they dance to when
they're all wearing the Statue of
Liberty yeah and Leeanne Locken is in
she's an extra and that's whatever it is
there's go to the soundtrack and find a
song like that would have been amazing
yeah whatever it's a I learned last
night that not even the pros choose a
song it's the producers yes and by the
way I actually did I tell you guys this
I did ask Lauren Elena if she gets to
choose what she wears and she said no
mm-hmm just some interesting factoids
interesting the politician the
politician is something we've got to
recap it came out on Friday already
finished it to only eight episodes we've
got Ben clap we've got quite a couch Oh
literally so happy to have them both on
my screen Ben Platt is singing like it's
just first of all like there's such a
few so few like good shows on TV that
when you get them like you don't want to
finish them yeah and it's so beautifully
done like their houses and that outfits
like it's all beautiful and it's just
such an interesting pilot like you don't
think it's a plot you don't know where
it where it's gonna go and where it and
certainly not where it began oh so we're
about to spoil the whole miniseries so
if you didn't watch it go watch I'm
crazy yes
um we'll see tomorrow um when when they
brought in Judith Light and Bette Midler
I was incredibly confused and I was
waiting for the link and then McAfee
went to go work there like is that the
link and then I understood it and I
actually think the second season is
gonna be much better than the present
because this is a plot I can get behind
at some points I was like this is a
little dramatic for high school [ __ ]
you know I thought it was just cool and
interesting it's like the an election
but like down to like the high school
level and you really get to it's
essential yeah and you know what I
thought was just like the best part of
it it's just a common theme it was like
you can choose to live your life
perfectly like knowing you're going to
run for president one day right doing
everything right saying everything right
you know never getting in trouble not
knowing that everything will be used
against you one day and you still [ __ ]
up yeah scene in the train station where
Gweneth Paltrow talking to Ben flat but
basically about canceled culture um
where she's like life is a [ __ ] store
when you got to grab as many gold bars
as you can like I thought she was
talking to me like I was like yes I will
okay no and when she was like losing the
plan going to [ __ ] was the best thing
that ever happened to you is so true so
many times that I just think it's like
even if you try to be a perfect person
and do everything right knowing that
everything one day will be used against
you and you're gonna be running for
president yep it's impossible
it's apenas life is a [ __ ] storming you
just need to grab as many gold bars as
you can it was so true and Gweneth
Paltrow was my absolute favorite
character like my only note is that I
could abuse more of her because you I
actually felt like Brad Falchuk who
created the show like wrote the
character for her based on her because
in real life like she's so glamorous
she's so beautiful she's a movie star
Hollywood but she's also like the most
down-to-earth like loving good mom and
that's exactly what her character was
like you would think she's walking
around her house like with her old short
husband like with millions and dollars
in jewelry on like she's a [ __ ] but no
no you would think that but she's
actually the most amazing mother down to
meet hard warm yeah and I think that's
what when Paltrow really is in real life
like he's gotten to know her as a wife
and a mom and like she's so beautiful
and like you think she's just like this
princess but she's also like the best
mom ever
yeah I totally got that vibe but that it
was like a replica of her in real life
you know
yeah um overall the show we talked about
like I loved it I loved shows like this
and the attention to detail and the
quality and production value like I will
never complain about yeah like it was
there's something about it that was just
I felt like I was watching cartoon
people you know that's what it's a bit
rhetorical
it's very what was intended to be but
it's like it's like sake I don't know
it's something that we're trending
towards like I feel like scream queens
with so dappin it's a sorority like I
know so I think Brad Falchuk worked on
scream queens yeah he did and it's also
Ryan Murphy and that's what like Glee
wasn't like that Glee was like real
people this is like when that girl Alice
with the short haired she's the only
person I really would have recast I
thought she was terrible at first lady
when she was like talking about how she
passed the lie detector test and she was
just being like so not a person I was
just like who are these fake people I'm
watching yeah like a cartoon I agree I
actually really did not like her like
storyline or her at all I thought she
was a terrible actress and it wasn't
buying whatever she was selling exactly
they were like OTP at the end what yeah
no there's no sense yeah no I kind of
like that everyone was like jut not
gender-fluid like actually sexually
fluent yeah that's what it's like now
and it wasn't like a thing like are you
gay I can hold it against you yeah I
liked that and I loved Astrid oh my god
you see boynton is [ __ ] beautiful
like I obviously hated her character
because I wanted been hot to win but her
outfit and just her she was perfect and
Jessica Lange was excellent she's an
actress now and we were saying like this
was the Gypsy Rose biopic that I wanted
oh my god gypsy I was just talking about
that the other day
oh yes last night with Ben's parents cuz
they were like alive during the Gypsy
Rose of it all and I was ask them if
they saw the act and they just started
watching the politician they're like
it's the same thing I'm like yeah it is
but it's so much better like hey this
happened recently
Gypsy Rose happen we saw yeah yeah those
ladies know just a few years ago yes
she's still a teenager
alright as a young person does that make
sense why they don't know about it but
they I was saying how like the act was
so boring like it's a crazy one it's a
crazy story with a boring chanting so
hard to get it was so hard to get
through this is this is it yeah this was
the bicep Zoe Deutsch was she was such a
good actress that she was bothering me
so much yeah that's the point yes
like shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] okay yeah
then when she had like had hair and was
like oh she was like an author and like
was or should be like oh I love this so
II do it you know yeah
go away well maybe she was putting on
the list so that people would think that
she was sick or I mean it would she
thought she was sick she wasn't in on it
she wasn't in on it but I don't know
maybe yeah you're right
maybe her grandma didn't let her get her
teeth fixed well so most unrealistic
thing was that he would be friends with
Skye Skye was my least favorite
character oh yeah murder him yeah yeah
and she was just like a like holier than
thou you know but no the only my biggest
problem with the show is why did we have
bed platt playing run away 100 times and
I'm never saying it because he wouldn't
have been able to continue because you
couldn't see through your tears when he
sat down at the piano and I'm like what
is he gonna play and he played Vienna
like literally my favorite song I was
like so moved I couldn't breathe like I
was frozen in time oh yeah I need a
soundtrack and the song was so
applicable to the situation yep there
were like so many key moments that
really stood out to me one was that
conversation between Gweneth and Ben in
the train station like that is will
forever be like the most important
conversation ever had all the times he's
saying and I thought actually the river
stuff was like really beautiful oh my
god when he's hot so hot when he's
saying river I was just like I don't
know if the song is but I it's my new
favorite like I his voice I could listen
to him sing for days mm-hmm
like I can't wait for his Netflix
special I know I'm so Ben Platt had a
concert of Radio City Music Hall two
nights ago and he also film different
Affleck special and he had the audacity
to have it on Rosh Hashanah which is
literally one of the most heartbreaking
things ever because we couldn't go and I
was so emotional watching his Instagram
story he's like oh I can't believe we
missed it and it's like let his last
show for this album but like I feel like
I wouldn't have been able to handle
right I've just been sitting you know
that's what I want to do know in public
like that's so humiliating no it's not
like emotions you feel things roomful of
people that are just no not clear like
tearing sobbing yeah like like oh and I
told Claudia this I looked up the
setlist oh yeah
and one of the songs that he
oh but joy by Stevie Wonder that's great
I just love him so much and I watched
his performance at global citizen
festival and he's just really coming
into his own like artists like a Maggie
Rogers vibe yeah and I just I stand
united with Sam
oh when we stand hard and I really did
enjoy the show like what a treat just
like a little sweet treat oh yeah and
you know what was so great about it and
why I'm so appreciative and grateful to
Brad Falchuk it's like for understanding
noticing and appreciating the unique
talent that is Ben Platt like Ben Platt
in this industry had like a super hard
time getting to where he is and he's
still multi-talented like he's such a
like when you saw him in Gary Henson
like he's such a physical actor and he's
such a he's gonna cry and demand those
veins pop out of his neck and he's such
a talented singer like it takes a really
special person to see that understand it
and then build a show around it yeah I
just I'm so here for the appreciation of
the standing of been fought oh wait wait
apparently ingly Rachel Berry sings the
song river Oh
during the Christmas episode oh I just
watched it that's it Hannah let's listen
well I just I loved it like oh that's
all I want more yeah I'm excited for
season eight episodes I'm sorry it's not
gonna cut it I need like at least 11
yeah even though each episode was an
hour knows what episode was like 20
minutes what was that what was that I
thought I'm like today just start this
episode on the plane I was like wow it
must be like a time warp or something oh
my god I mean it was really annoying
like that's not cool
knuck whoa and I want like more rich
houses like when he almost what becoming
I don't have to move to Santa Barbara ya
know when he became poor I was like no
way yeah I'm sure he'll actually well
the mom made like over a hundred million
dollars just like selling your sisters
you know too much about proxy victims
and I want like no no she got to give
him like a like a cool 20 million to
live who's Ben's tuition no but it's
better for his story as a politician if
he goes from rich rags to riches to rags
again you know so here and he doesn't
need the money
no I know cuz that's not what he cares
about and like heaven will get money
from my campaign like tuition maybe got
a scholarship he's gonna get into
Harvard the yang get a scholarship to
NYU really big-time yeah that was like
that really is what happens to the kid
who didn't get into Harvard
this is my
go to NYU no action - my new roommate
was like accepted to every um Ivy League
out there and chaired a full scholarship
to NYU so that's why she was there and
she was always like making it a point to
know like for me to know that she was
smarter than man like I know judo is
correcting me and stuff and then one
time she ate the audacity corrects me
well like if I was like talking this up
she was just like always [ __ ] like
chime in when I was stalking her and I
was on the phone with someone I'm gonna
hit lets me it's on like the corner of
like second and house gym and she let
him on the phone she goes it's Houston
I'm like finally I know something that
you don't know how much actually its
house in damn damn your roommates oh my
god by the way we were talking about
this for our next patreon its October so
we have like five episodes this month
you just did an episode yesterday with
Ben but someone had suggested we do an
episode about prom in like high school
and I realized we should do like a
nostalgia themed series because we could
do one on freshman year roommate we
definitely could we definitely could
who's yours oh yeah wait who's here is
wait I'll tell you later
yeah no and why you they have a new
policy what you can't request your own
room if you know someone like us you're
not allowed it's random like the tunngle
it's better no it's not
I request in mind it was silly [ __ ] Joe
okay okay but you went to a college
where you didn't know like nobody you
knew was going there yeah kind of
million people I could have requested
yeah like yeah the kids from your high
school went to that college yeah no but
it's honestly there's no actually I have
a few friends like Sam and Dana were
freshman year roommates and then they
were set like through mutual friends
they knew each other and then they've
room together every single year of
college I think they're so living
together
just kidding they're engaged so Johnny
watch the politician Street Med plots
new album and have a great day
is there anything else we needed should
we cap uh no Shanah Tovah everyone we
know the team tomorrow it's available to
my to our girls no job comment hitting
up Milwaukee this weekend Sunday night
feel free to come through it's gonna be
lit there's like 10 tickets left
and then next week we're doing LA San
Diego San Francisco so tickets available
Carla jobs calm thank you so much for
listening to the morning show us the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday to Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so feel free just like this
video comment subscribe notifications
all that [ __ ] we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast
downsize iTunes Spotify stitcher public
radio I heard radio every every app all
the apps head over there leave a review
5 stars we love you have an amazing day
me we'll see you tomorrow tomorrow I
love ya tomorrow
you